♪ ♪
>> Tucker: LIKE MOST BIG-CITY
MAYORS, MURIEL BOWSER
WASHINGTON, D.C., HAS MADE LIFE
OR HER OWN RESIDENCE MUCH, MUCH
WORSE OVER THE COUPLE YEARS AND
THAT THE SAME TIME SHE SHOWED
GREAT CONCERN FOR ILLEGAL ALIENS
COME HERE.
SHE DECLARED WASHINGTON, D.C., A
SANCTUARY CITY.
SHE SAID THE CITY WOULD PAY TO
FIGHT THE GOVERNMENT'S EFFORTS
TO DEPORT PEOPLE.
SHE SAID THE CITY WOULD GIVE
ILLEGAL ALIENS FREE HOUSING,
HEALTH CARE, EDUCATION.
WELL, WHY WOULDN'T PEOPLE FROM
AROUND THE WORLD TAKE MURIEL
BOWSER UP ON HER OFFER?
THEY HAVE AND THEY HAVE MOVED
THERE IN HUGE NUMBERS.
THAT'S A WIN FOR DIVERSITY,
RIGHT?
NO.
IT TURNS OUT MURIEL BOWSER AND
WE DON'T USE THIS WORD LIGHTLY
IS A WHITE SUPREMACIST.
MAYBE EVEN A WHITE NATIONALIST.
SHE HAS CLAIMING THIS NEW
DIVERSITY IS A HUMANITARIAN
CRISIS.
SHE IS SUCH A RACIST SHE WANTS
THE ARMY TO COME IN.
>> I HAVE ASKED FOR THE
DEPLOYMENT OF THE GUARD AS LONG
AS WE NEED THE GUARD TO DEAL
WITH THE HUMANITARIAN CRISIS.
THAT WE EXPECT TO ESCALATE.
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE CROSSING
THE BORDER SEEKING ASYLUM, WE
EXPECT TO ONLY GO UP.
AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE IS A NATIONAL RESPONSE.
>> Tucker: CHIP ROY IS A
CONGRESSMAN FROM TEXAS.
HE'S BEEN TO THE BORDER NUMEROUS
TIMES.
CONGRESSMAN, THANKS FOR COMING
ON.
WE ARE MAKING FUN OF MURIEL
BOWSER, ONE OF THE MOST
INCOMPETENT PEOPLE EVER TO HOLD
OFFICE IN THIS COUNTRY.
ON THE OTHER HAND, SHE IS
CALLING OUT THE NATIONAL GUARD
TO DEAL WITH ILLEGAL ALIENS.
WHAT ARE THE GOVERNORS OF REAL
STATES DOING THAT ACTUALLY?
>> YOU KNOW, TUCKER, IT'S
INTERESTING HEARING THE MAYOR OF
WASHINGTON, D.C., WHICH IS WHERE
I'M SITTING RIGHT NOW, COMBINING
ABOUT 4,000 PEOPLE ON 200 BUSES
THAT GOVERNOR ABBOTT HAS SENT TO
WASHINGTON, D.C., SINCE APRIL
RUN INTO THE PENTAGON SAYING OH,
MY GOSH, WE NEED THE
NATIONAL GUARD.
CRIMEA FREAKING RIVER.
WELCOME TO THE PARTY, PAL.
IN TEXAS TODAY WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE 7,000 PEOPLE CROSSING THE
BORDER AND HALF OF THAT IN
TEXAS.
CRY ME A RIVER ABOUT THE 50 50
BODIES IN TEXAS IN THE MORGUE
WHERE THE SHERIFF IS DEALING
WITH DEAD MIGRANTS.
TALK TO THE FAMILIES THAT ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE PEOPLE
PACKING PISTOLS.
THIS ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT.
I GOT THIS PICTURE AND HOUR AGO
THE COUNTY ATTORNEY.
WELCOME TO THE PARTY.
I DON'T WANT TO HEAR YOUR
COMPLAINING.
WE WANT TO TALK ABOUT RACISM?
HOW ABOUT THE RACISM ABOUT THE
DHS FORCING BORDER PATROL AGENTS
TO BE ACCUSED OF WHIPPING
PATIENCE AND BEING CALLED RACIST
WITH A COMPLETELY UNFOUNDED